you know I didn't have to audition for
Mandalorian they didn't have to audition
for uh The Walking Dead I didn't
audition for either one of these movies
that I did pieces of content that I did
um so I forgot what was your question no
about like what you want like well yeah
you know what I don't I don't I don't
you're content I'm very content I'm very
content I'm content because I know that
I've got a career
that already you know when you're in a
movie
like just Terminator aliens and I was
retired I'd been like I did it I was a
movie star I I'm done I thought I was
gonna retire and then you know
Mandalorian came along and there's just
certain people like John Favre that you
just don't say no to yeah they'll still
want to see you yeah can you come in and
and support Rose Rosario Dawson who by
the way is awesome on the
podcast too yeah she's going to yeah oh
she's awesome
yeah tell her right you know she she
knows how I feel about her and uh
there's just certain people uh and then
you know when I did The Walking Dead it
was Greg nicotero who had done all the
special effects on Robert Rodriguez's
movie was is now the showrunner on that
and
um so I'm not I'm not very good at
auditioning but I'm once I really sink
my teeth into something
um I feel yeah I feel pretty pretty good